do you guys have like the
anti-earthquake proof stuff in like your
cabinets you probably should do that no
it really does make a difference that's
it yeah what is it so basically like oh
i mean there's lots of different
variations of it but i need it for most
stuff though i feel like it's for very
specific things um i we put it on most
stuff like most of the big stuff so like
if you have like uh figuring cabinets or
like bookshelves this is like little
kind of like they look like little
rubber door stops yeah i know oh no you
put them underneath and it completely
stops the shaking from happening yeah i
wanted to get the figures to stop
shaking yes i have i have them under
like all of my bookshelves and figurine
cabinets and stuff like that and you
know i've seen them move in an
earthquake that [ __ ] doesn't budge so
that's really good and also like there's
also these like little like sticky pads
kind of thing that you can put on like
some like figurines and stuff like that
that's just weird that you have to like
live in a country and you just worry
about like just like like insta death
just happening like in the uk like
nothing kills people
i mean it's not exactly insta-death oh
just worry well i mean it might be
if you're in the wrong situation yeah
yeah yeah
i mean i suppose like i've we've been
lucky enough to never have been in a bad
earthquake
i don't like like i i feel like
don't [ __ ] say
well they've been predicting the mega
quake for like a few years now in tokyo
yeah yeah yeah where there's a bound to
be some kind of like tokyo
eight or nine yeah yeah [ __ ]
earthquake in tokyo and i'm not i hope
to god it happens in the next three
weeks i'm not here
jesus christ i bet you'll wish you were
on the ground floor then
connor all i'll say well i felt like the
shaking was very violent i used to live
on like a fourth or fifth floor and it
used to shake really weirdly i didn't
like it i felt like it was just high
enough up where i got really [ __ ]
violent shirts yeah yeah i got i was on
the eighth floor and i think with the
the biggest earthquake we were in which
uh was the one where earthquake
earthquake earthquake the biggest
earthquake we were in which was the one
where the fig my figures fell over uh
that wasn't the toilet at the time but
like that's the safest room to be in
yeah i was in the math one time as well
but that earthquake just lasted for so
[ __ ] long it sounded like it lasted
like two minutes or something at least
yeah yeah going wrong yeah because it
just it just started and like at which
point because you have to make this
mental judgment of at which point do i
start giving a [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah because because most of the time
it's a little because it happens so
often it happens so often so i'm just
like oh is this the one i should start
carrying yeah it's not stopping should i
start caring now but also what are you
gonna do if you give a [ __ ] like what am
i going to do just be like oh [ __ ] i'm
worried well you have to like evacuate
to your nearest evacuation point which
everyone should know when you move no
where is this
we got you got to get under the door
frame right if it's door frame but also
like if it gets really bad then there's
like in your local town there's usually
like evacuation points that's normally
if like your water and [ __ ] turns off
and all that is right um no it's in a
lot of situations it's like earthquakes
and floods and stuff like that yeah why
why would you leave your house in an
earthquake if it's like that's surely if
it's like unstable though well i mean
what if the building's on it's usually
in the case of like you know if the
earthquake is really powerful that your
water stops all your electricity stops
your gas that's what i thought right it
was to get like supplies and shelter
yeah because if the winter if it's
really [ __ ] cold and you know your
electricity turns off and then you kind
of screw which i'm kind of [ __ ]
because like i am not stocked up on any
kind of emergency
disaster yeah we recently like restocked
our ships like all over the front
it's been meaningful yeah two years
remember like uh for journey across
japan we went to like sakurajima which
is that like island uh or volcano
yeah in kagoshima and i remember like
two weeks after we left there it [ __ ]
erupted
and it's like and that entitled it was
like pretty big as well and it made me
realize i was like oh yeah earthquakes
are like the least of my worries because
japan is like [ __ ] volcanic area
there's like so many active like food
malfuji is a [ __ ] active volcano is
it yeah it is
it is it's a and it's it's an active
volcano and it last erupted i think
about 250 years ago and they're
expecting it 250 years ago yeah in like
the other period it last erupted oh and
then they're expecting it to erupt like
soon sick so i'm like
sick
they actually did a simulation if it
erupts completely yeah it actually
reaches all the way to uh
uh oh sure it's still that far yeah wow
it's kind of like a yellowstone right in
america that's like one of the biggest
active super volcanoes in the world yeah
if that erupts then it's just like kind
of like the end of civilization for like
a lot of people yeah exactly yeah
because a lot of the waters at
yellowstone are like boiling hot like
the lakes yeah yeah exactly yeah some
horrifying stories people jumping in the
water
thinking that they can swim in it oh and
it's boiling
oh that's uh that's probably but i i
don't know when it's so bad when do i
leave my house i i don't know that does
is it like a hard guide on what i mean i
mean i'm pretty sure you'll know when
you're no yeah you know what i mean like
when it gets to the point where it's
like oh i can't be here for a multitude
of reasons then it's time to go yeah the
ones that i don't really get scared of
the earthquakes in japan but the ones
that do kind of make me uncomfortable is
when it starts small and it just keeps
getting bigger yeah and then you're like
when will it stop will it keep
escalating yeah because when it starts
off big and it doesn't get any worse i'm
like okay
okay cool it's the it's the long ones
for me though yeah yeah right where it
starts you like shakes
shakes shakes and you're like please
okay please please stop yeah i was like
when is this going to peak yeah
this is the peak no it's not peaking yet
i just feel like it's the british in me
where you just don't take any kind of
like natural disaster seriously i'm just
like come on
sorry stop this now come on i've got
enough of this i'm british it's a
natural disaster come on there's no
natural disasters in the world so you
guys don't have like any natural
disasters no there's some flooding but
very light it's not right right
yeah we have flooding here like like i i
hear i hear like of like uh like uh like
a weather warning in japan i'm just like
what the [ __ ] the weather warning how
come whether the phone has been on
permanent weather warning since i've
moved here i'm pretty sure yeah but i'd
love to imagine the first time like a
british person like went abroad right in
like 1600s and they're like
there's an earthquake like what the [ __ ]
was that what the [ __ ] was that and
they're like yeah that happens all the
time what do you mean that happens all
the time the earth just moves the earth
just moves and you're all okay with this
you haven't asked management what's
going on it's all living
and then like yeah yeah yeah and
sometimes the the mountain explodes the
mountain explodes
and fire
the mountain explodes we get these
things called typhoons yeah they're like
what do you mean lava that's hell
there's hell coming out that's we've
only seen that in the books this doesn't
happen what is this is nonsense there's
you accept this this is okay with you
it's like what is a typhoon it's just a
bit of wind in it a bit of winds never
hurt anyone just a bit of rain we get
that all the time
it's bit of rain and wind what do you
mean nature destroyed your house and did
you get a refund what is all this what
is a tsunami it's just just a wave isn't
it
yeah
yeah when we think about it we japan
really is like world number one when it
comes to like the variety of [ __ ]
things that can kill you in nature yeah
we really do have everything because i
remember before like i moved out of
england you'd hear about these disasters
that happened all the way in the other
side of the world
right it's like like the japan tsunami
which is like an awful tragedy that
happens and you just didn't it didn't it
never quite sank him yeah that felt real
like how how bad it was like i remember
just before we moved to japan where like
you guys were having like super bad thai
few and typhoons and like the
the videos that came out just look super
bad and yeah just like
i i it still doesn't sink into me that
it's just this bad here in japan yeah as
a british person because i've just never
experienced it
irl in real life like it's never just
happened right in front of me it really
it really is like completely different
like you could watch like hundreds of
videos on it and the one that you've
actually experienced in real life is
like unlike anything you would ever
imagine it is like it's like those
typhoons look bad it's a hundred times
worse in real life watching like
earthquakes from like the 2011
earthquake uh it's like really [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] terrifying yeah just seeing
like people just everything's shaking
super violently i'm like oh gosh and
just like the water level rising and
[ __ ] is like terrifying that happened 10
years ago man
yeah it's weird yeah time flies 2011
holy [ __ ] i was still in
university i would gladly take um
volcanoes if we can get onsens
stick a volcano somewhere in wales i
will have an onsen